[Music]
you have a real flair for style and you
love bowties love bowties they look good
on you when did the bowtie thing take
off for you when did you realize I like
bowties well before I before us they
that actually have something for you I
thought um that this might you know you
brought that for me all right
I'll try that on sure yeah I'll try I've
never tried a boat you don't even have
to side you can see what I like don't be
so condescending look coning even you
can do it alright I'll try this on this
could be a good look for me
[Applause]
I'm good we're good I look real good
Angus go then he's just giving me a very
neutral
you look like Leggett admissions
counselor in America like I'm sorry
you're not quite
Westwood material
good against that's animal and put Delta
house yeah I have to ask you a question
you are so good have you ever thought
okay what about the NBA have you thought
about competing in the NBA or at least
trying out
Mark Cuban actually uh said he would
consider it and I actually would child
you know I'll actually go try to play
out with the play with boys yeah I think
I definitely got there try to get a
couple of blocks right so do you think
this is gonna actually happen you think
it's possible I'm waiting on the call
right yeah just gonna pay you in bacon
now before we go we please wear that as
a headband
[Applause]
[Music]
that's cute the elastic gives you the
option necktie why do I listen to you I
wonder the same thing